When I was a student. In fact, when I was at high school,
we had to do analytical chemistry,
trying to identify different irons, like bromide, iodide,
chloride, and we did all sorts of tests.
So I thought it'd be quite fun to get Sam to do one of these things.
These tests.
Look really quite pretty. The, when I was a school, boy,
I found them really tedious.
It involves adding silver nitrate to the solutions and you get to
precipitate. When you add the silver nitrate,
you get silver ions in the solution,
which also contains nitrate because you put in silver nitrate,
but also chloride or bring my door iodide.
And the silver highlights are very insoluble.
So when the silver and the Haylight Dan's meet,
they form a solid and precipitate.
So there is quite a nice reaction and you get a
precipitate of different colors,
depending which halogen you use. So as a test,
although I didn't mention this to Sam,
she decided she would use fluoride as well.
That's all for halogens.
You can get easily as the teen and the new one, Tennessee,
aren't really available to do lab experiments.
Silver ions with fluoride was a bit
disappointing. Silver fluoride is reasonably soluble in water.
So you don't form a precipitate with silver chloride.
You get a fairly white precipitate and these precipitation reactions
take place incredibly fast,
much faster than your eye can follow.
This is not something that gradually develops. One minute. It's clear.
Next minute, silver bromide is pale yellow.
And silver.
Now, what am I telling you about these compounds?
And the reason is that these silver highlights have been
technologically very important,
particularly silver Bromite because silver bromide was the
material that was used for old-fashioned photographic film.
Nowadays, everybody takes digital pictures,
but until really quite recently,
most photographs were taken on film and the film
has a layer of silver bromide, crystals, very small ones.
And the amazing thing about silver broom and crystals is that when
they absorb light, they are dissociated.
So you get silver metal formed.
You don't get very much silver metal formed,
but then when you put it into developing solution,
that tiny piece of silver acts as a catalyst and bigger
particles grow to give you the black color and black and white film.
I hope one day we will be able to show you in the dark room,
the chemistry of film,
but this compound that sitting in the test tube is the basis of all
photographic film. There is one quite funny question,
which people sometimes ask,
which is what is the color of unexposed photographic film
that is film, which has not been exposed to light,
because if you want to know the color of something,
you have to shine light on it. And if you sign light on it,
the film has been exposed.
So.
Nobody really knows what the color of unexposed film is.
And silver iodide crystals have a really
unexpected application,
which is to make rain in the sky.
There's a lot of water vapor and the water vapor can condense to form
clouds and the clouds produce rain.
The problem is that water vapor has to be cooled to very low temperature
before it will spontaneously form crystals of ice.
But if there are tiny particles in the air,
this acts as a nucleus and the water droplets or ice particles can form
random shortly after the second world war, about 70 years ago,
it was suddenly realized that the structure of the crystals of silver
iodide have the same sort of spacing of the atoms as in crystals of
ice. So people have the idea of injecting, very fine,
powders of silver iodide into the air,
where clouds were forming to make them form thicker clouds and therefore
terrain. And it works,
but nobody quite knows how and most recently people have done
experiments.
And so the ice doesn't form in the way that people thought.
And so the spacing of the atoms on the silver iodide is not
the relevant property, but it still seems to work.
And so in many countries now people use silver
iodide for seeding clouds.
Did I lie? Now.
There are two reasons for seeding clouds.
One reason is to make it rain,
to make your plants grow better.
The other reason is to get the clouds to
start producing rain before a real storm starts.
If you don't see the clouds, then they build up and up and up,
and then suddenly it stopped producing large hail stones,
which can cause enormous damage, smashing buildings, denting cars, and so on.
So silver iodide can reduce,
or people believe that it can reduce the force of a
storm and cause less damage underneath.
To one side. Yep. In fact, before we do that,
I want to take a selfie with it.
This is me and the first paper to describe like photos properly.
You lock in that.
Got it. Yep. They range in price depending on what the scene is.
It's artistic value from around 10,000 pounds to
the most expensive print in this box has been valued at half a million pounds
for one photograph, half a million pounds.